15h dans la banlieue ouest de londres
l'heure pour ahmed un afghan de 33 ans
de s'engouffrer dans son qg
cette pizzeria en sous sol c'est son
gagne pain six jours sur sept c'est le
même rituel ouvrir la boutique branchée
les caisses et prier c'est ici que je
prie ahmed a fui la guerre les talibans
en 2002 après plusieurs mois de périple
clandestin à travers l'europe il
débarque en angleterre ici réside près
de 70 mille afghans et parmi eux ahmed a
pu compter sur un ami pour l'aider à
s'installer
c'est que j'ai mis six mois à rejoindre
mon ami celui qui m'a aidé à venir à
londres
il m'a trouvé un boulot un logement à
partager avec d'autres colocataires
si tu n'as pas d'amis ici quelqu'un pour
t'aider c'est vraiment très dur de
trouver du travail
grâce à son patron afghan lui aussi
ahmed est passé maître dans l'art de la
pizza à l'ombre
x je ne savais pas faire cuire un oeuf é
même faire le thé rien
en afghanistan c'est ma mère qui faisait
tout
mais maintenant je dois tout faire tout
seul
je dois faire la cuisine laver mes
vêtements pourquoi
mais bon ça fait déjà un bout de temps
à mettre fait partie de la dernière
vague de réfugiés afghans depuis 30 ans
ils sont des millions à avoir quitté
leur terre à travers les montagnes
l'afghanistan c'est trente années de
guerres successives en 1979 en pleine
guerre froide le pays est envahi par les
russes onze ans de résistance farouche
en viendrons à bout puis c'est la guerre
civile et l'avènement 1996 du régime des
talibans exécution publique interdiction
des jeux et de la musique droits des
femmes réduit à néant ils font régner la
terreur et abrite les terroristes du 11
septembre les états unis renversent le
régime en 2002 mais les talibans ne
baisse pas les armes l'an dernier encore
le conflit a fait plus de dix mille
morts
retour à londres church road c'est ici
que réside ahmed dans l'un des
principaux quartiers afghans de la
capitale au quotidien il ne côtoie
pratiquement que des afghans premier
point de ralliement l'épicerie à côté de
la mosquée
tout est comme dans mon pays si j'ai
envie de manger afghans je viens ici
regardez ce rayon de disques
ce ne sont que des artistes à 20 ans
les avions qui ont vécu sous le régime
taliban et qui arrive est ici on
trouvait enfin leur culture et leur
musique
ahmed a trouvé de quoi se loger juste au
dessus de la mosquée la vie à londres
coûte cher alors ils partagent cette
chambre à 400 euros par mois avec deux
parfois trois amis afghans
[Musique]
matt est placé mon lit le lit de mon ami
quand je suis arrivé ici je me sentais
très mal j'étais vraiment triste d'être
séparé de ma famille j'allais pas bien
ahmed n'a pas quitté sa famille pour la
qualité de vie anglaise mais bien pour
survivre il y a dix ans en afghanistan
être jeune signifiait partir au front
contre les américains
après le 11 septembre 2001 les talibans
ont capturé tous les jeunes garçons font
les ont pris de force et les ont obligés
à aller combattre dans le nord
aussi je me suis retrouvé là bas durant
trois quatre jours
mais ma chance c'est que je connaissais
bien la région
comme je déteste me battre
j'ai cherché un moyen de m'échapper
et après avec trois ou quatre autres
personnes on a réussi à s'enfuir
ahmed rejoint alors kaboul la son père
des bourses 7000 $ pour payer un passeur
à pied puis cachés dans des conteneurs
il atteint le nord de la france six mois
plus tard quelques jours dans le hangar
de sangatte puis il traverse le channel
planqué dans un train aujourd'hui ahmed
a obtenu son visa après huit années de
clandestinité
ici en angleterre si tu marches le droit
que tu respecte les règles une personne
ne te demande de rien
si tu es musulman et que tu vas à la
mosquée ou que tu es une femme et que tu
te couvre avec un jam on te dit rien
surtout à londres tu es libre
même si l'angleterre durci ces lois sur
l'immigration
sa tolérance en fait la destination
favorite des réfugiés afghans prochaine
étape pourra mettre dans un an il pourra
alors passer le test de citoyenneté et
obtenir la nationalité anglaise
pour réussir le test de citoyenneté la
condition première c'est de parler
l'anglais et la maîtrise de la langue
c'est un peu le cheval de bataille de
chaabi cette afghane de 62 ans a fui
l'invasion russe pour londres en 1984 à
kaboul chabib y était professeur
d'université et publier des poèmes en
dari l'une des deux langues officielles
du pays mais ici au chevet de son mari
malade avec trois enfants à éduquer chat
bibi a passé dix ans sans pouvoir
s'exprimer
j'ai appris la langue très tard j'avais
à peu près 45 ans et croyez moi ce
n'était pas facile
ce n'est qu'après le décès de son époux
que cha bibi a appris l'anglais elle
s'est engagée au sein d'associations
pour l'accueil de réfugiés et la
condition des femmes
cet après midi elle est attendue dans
l'ouest londonien où vivent 70% des
afghans de la capitale
rendez-vous à west side radio ici les
programmes sont en dari
[Musique]
le
groupe isa à michel jestin
bombardé cette partie d'organes
maimonides orange recherches de rennes
i non hilton et son smic même que leur
mère a dit mahmoud chamman
match
qui
marquait
même et les airs
fin de journée nous retrouvons chat bibi
chez elle à l'heure du thé une coutume
so british comme celle d'entretenir son
petit jardin à l'angle est bien sûr j'ai
remporté ce premier prix de jardinage
mais c'est un tout petit jardin j'adore
jardiner
mais la plus grande fierté de chaabi
biais après la réussite professionnelle
de ces enfants c'est d'avoir pris la
plume dans la langue de shakespeare dans
son livre where do we belong traduisait
d'où je viens elle raconte son exil un
mari journaliste torturé par le régime
pro russe puis la fuite seule avec trois
enfants dont un bébé de quatre mois au
creux des bras étaient des étapes n
avons rien peut prendre avec nos clubs
sauf un vêtement qu'on partait or durant
quinze jours le long du chemin qui nous
a mené jusqu'au pakistan ap slowplay
nous avons eu très très frotte
n'avons fait que marcher ce toit marché
est encore marcher jusqu'à atteindre le
pakistan auxtin quand j'ai mon bon ça je
me dis que j'ai vraiment été courageuse
et
de sa vie afghane chat bibi n'a pu
conserver que quelques photos pour elle
les années 70 c'était l'âge d'or où
kaboul s'initier à la démocratie quand
elle est retourné au pays en 2004 elle
n'a plus rien reconnu
la condition des femmes là-bas m'a brisé
le coeur
nous n'avions pas ça avant bien sûr
l'afghanistan n'a jamais été un pays
très accueillant ont pas de jallet mais
c'était tout de même une civilisation
batna mais aujourd'hui regardez ce que
cette venue cette situation est triste
malheureusement une fortune est vraiment
triste
retour à church road le quartier d'ahmed
il est midi et c'est la fin de la
seconde prière de la journée dans
l'épicerie d'à côté monsieur nessakh le
patron des lieux voit défiler toutes les
générations d'afghans mais c'est sur la
dernière celle qui est née ici à londres
qu'il compte pour reconstruire son pays
arabes celle d'hélène des abdos enfants
ont eu l'opportunité d'étudier ici
beaucoup d'entre eux ont fini l'école où
sont à l'université
certains d'entre eux retournent au pays
pour y travailler
nous espérons que dans un avenir proche
qui ne pourront y retourner aussi car
c'est à nous de reconstruire notre pays
ce n'est pas aux étrangers de le faire
jadis d'étrangers ne sont là que pour
nous aider
ahmed aussi n'a qu'un souhait retrouver
sa famille dans un afghanistan pacifié
là bas malgré la résistance des talibans
le retrait des 140 mille soldats de
l'alliance devrait s'engager en juillet
prochain mais ahmed sait qu'il faudra
être patient avant de revoir le
printemps afghans